[Música]
o
bien
los malhumorados podemos cambiar el
mundo y hemos sido mal incomprendidos
[Risas]
hay una una de las cosas que a mí tanto
me molesta son las etiquetas esas
definiciones que los demás hacen sobre
nosotros o que nosotros hacemos de los
demás y que los resumimos en un par de
palabras cuando yo era muy pequeña más o
menos a los seis años me etiquetaron
como mal genia da como se dice en mi
país y eso hacía que me pusiera de peor
peor humor
llevo aproximadamente 36 años de
experiencia con esa etiqueta entonces sé
muy bien de lo que hablo aunque
realmente fue preparando esta charla que
me di cuenta
que si era malhumorada y acepte que era
malhumorada porque no es fácil de
aceptar generalmente aceptamos las
emociones que tienen consecuencias
positivas pero no las emociones que
tienen consecuencias negativas no
podemos hablar de consecuencias paradón
de emociones positivas y emociones
negativas sino de las consecuencias si
yo estoy acá y les sonrío pues la
consecuencia va a ser positiva si yo
entro acá
enojada como estaba hace tres días más
no la consecuencia no va a ser muy muy
buena entonces se trata de ver qué es lo
que está pasando con con ese mal humor
cuando yo empiezo a preparar la charla
empezaba a problema de mal humor sola me
despertaba de mal humor me despertaba a
prender el boiler yo siempre porque soy
tan de mal humor que es lo que está
pasando justo el día que tenía que armar
el guión porque detrás de esto hay una
infraestructura impresionante venía para
el trabajo y estaba de peor humor cada
vez ellos decían ok tú eres coach que es
lo que está pasando aquí
y me di cuenta que habían pequeñas cosas
que me estaban frustrando en mi vida y
es que la frustración las injusticias
hacen que se detone el mal humor
y se siente horrible yo empiezo a sentir
como la mandíbula se me empieza a
trabajar y el cuello también se contrae
y también una cosa aquí en el estómago
que hace que no pueda comer muy bien y
explotó no
y todos tenemos ese tipo de sensaciones
físicas mi novio que es psicólogo y que
por aquí está me lo justifico muy bien y
me dice amor escritores chaparrita y hay
algo en psicología que se llama
mecanismo de defensa y eso es un
mecanismo de compensación necesitas
sentirte segura y dar demostrar
autoridad ante la jce y con eso está
bien suficiente la podía justificarme y
mal humor bueno por lo menos entenderlo
un poco mejor porque es en serio no lo
aceptaba y no lo entendía y creo que a
todos nos pasa es difícil poder
entenderlo pero empecé entonces a
trabajar un poco con esta parte de las
emociones y dije yo sé que todas las
emociones tienen un mensaje detrás cuál
es el mensaje del mal humor
y el mal humor aparte de ese mensaje
tiene una energía muy fuerte creo que
todos hemos sentido o hemos proyectado
esa energía en otro a veces son las
palabras que salen con más fuerza y que
lastiman a veces son las acciones
físicas en las que desafortunadamente
podríamos llegar a matar a otras
personas y estamos muy bien
pero que en condiciones normales pues no
haríamos entonces la idea es tratar de
entender que el mal humor tiene toda esa
carga energética que lo que está
buscando y nos pide a gritos son cambios
que cambiemos algo a veces nos enoja
nuestros amigos nos enoja nuestra pareja
o nos enoja nuestras circunstancias y a
veces es más fácil cambiar de amigos o
cambiar de pareja o cambiar de
circunstancia o empezar a pensar que
debo cambiar yo también dentro de mí y
el mensaje oculto del enojo siempre va a
ser busca ese cambio así como el miedo y
los nervios así deliciosos que hemos
sentido todos los speakers antes nos
están tratando de dar seguridad y
tranquilidad
y los sentimos de diferentes maneras
ansiosos nerviosos nos volvemos los
dedos etcétera pero cada emoción nos
está dando un mensaje estoy segura que
maná está se enojó muchísimo en muchas
circunstancias con su discapacidad si
estuvieron en el primer bloque sé que
carolina se enojó muchísimo cuando
estaba tratando de descubrir qué pasaba
con su hijo así como cada uno de
nosotros se enoja y a veces tratamos de
ocultarlo yo también
yo medite yo me enojaba sola yo me
enojaba feo trataba de enojarme bonito y
trataba de no enojarme que no se me
notara que si es más yo sé que mi jefa
que estaba por allí no sabe que soy
malhumorada y se está enterando hasta
hoy sí y no es malo porque lo que he
hecho es tratar de poner a favor
esa emoción de decir ok qué es lo que
necesito cambiar ahora lo puedo cambiar
o debo buscar la manera en la que esta
frustración no se vuelva algo más grande
porque hay muchos que han hecho muchas
por el mundo por el planeta por su
familia y no solamente explotar y no
solamente agredir y no solamente
imponerse subiendo la voz o pellizcando
dando en chanclas o ahora que estaban
tan de moda los memes de las mamás y sus
enojos y no se trata de eso se trata de
saber qué es lo que necesito cambiar y
si necesito buscar una manera de que
esto cambie o aprender a manejar esa
frustración la mayoría de ustedes tres
son de aquí y el norte tiene fama de ser
mal humorados para otra parte del país y
les dicen estás enojado que estás
hablando así tan fuerte cito yo los
invito a que la próxima vez les digan sí
si estoy enojado y estoy tratando de
cambiar mi estado mi ciudad las
circunstancias tan negativas que tenemos
a mi familia de trabajar mejor de tener
una mejor familia así si estoy enojado
pero estoy tratando de usar ese enojo
para algo yo no tengo idea todavía muy
bien que era lo que pasaba conmigo
cuando estaba pequeñita que me enojaba
tanto posiblemente quería que me
explicaran porque lo que quería no se
podía en ese momento tal vez quería que
alguien me pasara y me dijera sí ya nos
vamos no pongas esa cara no lo sé pero
sí sé lo que aprendí y lo que aprendí es
eso que cada vez que me enojo puedo usar
ese enojo para algo no para dañar mis
relaciones de trabajo ya te vi silvia no
para dañar a mis alumnos no para dañar a
las personas que quiero y que conozco y
los invito a que hagan esa misma
reflexión cada vez que ven a alguien
enojado se pregunten qué querrá cambiar
que necesita cambiar y cada vez que
ustedes se enojen se en ese pequeño
espacio dos minutos tres minutos cuatro
días seis meses para reflexionar qué es
lo que puedo cambiar y lo que quiero
cambiar y que después den un paso a
favor de ese cambio que necesiten y no
se queden solamente en la reacción
porque todos conocemos cuáles son las
consecuencias negativas de ese enojo y
no nos enojemos simplemente por todo
claro que está bien enojarse está bien
sentir todas las emociones pero saber
para qué lo estoy haciendo y encontrarle
la utilidad no solamente explotar
entonces tampoco les estoy diciendo que
se enojen y que esta señorita colombiana
coach y les dijo que ahora si podían
sacar todo el enojo que traían hay que
encauzarlo y hay que encauzarlo a favor
nuestro y a favor de los demás
[Aplausos]
[Música]